what's up everybody welcome back to the
cosmic wonder I'm your host Warren
Thompson and this is going to be my
black panther wakanda forever no spoiler
review we're not going to be talking
about spoilers in this video although I
can't wait until we do the non-spoiler
review and hopefully a live discussion
about this film because there's so much
to talk about this is a
big movie it is a big movie but at the
same time what's really cool is that it
actually felt very much just like a
sequel to the first black panther yes
it's connected to the MCU yes you you
see those connections and you feel like
of course it takes place inside of the
MCU especially with some scenes where
you know Queen raimonda is talking to
the United Nations about you know
wakanda now being public to the world
and vibranium so it's very much
connected but at the same time the story
very much just hones in on a sequel to
the first Black Panther movie all you
need to see to watch this movie is the
first black panther film which is pretty
cool which is pretty cool now I've heard
a ton of reviews from you know my
friends other creators critics who have
seen this movie and they're mostly
positive most of them I do think fans
some fans are going to be have someone
of a mixed opinion about this film I
rank it pretty high but it's not a
perfect film by any means but there's a
lot of greatness that comes with it and
it has its flaws which we're going to
talk about as well I'm kind of gonna mix
in we're going to talk about good bad
and then good because I want to end on a
positive note because there are truly a
lot of amazing things to talk about with
this film
first thing I have to talk about I feel
like everyone's talking about it but I
would be remiss if I didn't talk about
it is the acting it's
this is emotional movie for the fans it
really is and Chadwick Boseman to me was
an incredible actor there's so many
movies that he's in that I I love him in
and I respect him so much as an actor
and I'm super sad that he's gone I'm you
know I'm sure as many people are but it
it was so emotional for the fans for me
as a fan but I know it was also
extremely emotional
for everybody involved in making the
film
all the actors
at some point in time when you start
watching the film
I I was wondering like is this acting or
is this just them grieving which is like
really cool
because it's real right it's almost not
acting it's almost just them going
through this process of dealing with the
death of a friend and I almost feel bad
for them because I'm sure they grieved
in their very own ways you know before
the movie started shooting again but
then they had to go back into the movie
and then you know all of a sudden
they're dealing with the death of a
character but the character was you know
their friend in real life so they have
to almost relive that I almost feel you
know kind of bad for them but I can I
can honestly say like across the board
everyone's acting in this was phenomenal
like okay I saw Black Adam and one part
I really hated about Black Adam was the
acting like a lot of the side characters
stuff like that I was like it's kind of
ruining the movie for me but in this
it's like it makes the movie how good
everyone's acting is
like everyone Queen raimonda shuri um
Baku you just nameor or nemour which no
spoilers but you'll find out why he's
called uh it's actually not pronounced
name or it's nemour in this film and
you'll you'll find out why they they do
a good reason why I have many names
my people call me
well my enemies call me Namor the story
is kind of what I thought it was going
to be like but also wasn't at the same
time which I actually enjoyed because it
seemed like they were making some things
pretty clear
you know because it's marveled a ton of
TV spots come out before these movies
come out uh a ton of trailers all this
stuff you know
um so I didn't you know I couldn't guess
everything which I which I appreciate I
definitely appreciated that
it this is gonna be
so far and probably for a while I would
say the most emotional film and the most
serious film of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe which I appreciated a lot of
people always talk about you know we had
some serious Parts but then they ruined
it with the Marvel comedy that doesn't
really happen yes there are some jokes
of course it's still the MCU it's still
a Marvel film there are jokes in the
movie but the seriousness of it is not
you know it's not undercut by a corny
joke or something like that which I
really appreciated and big props to Ryan
coogler because I know with Chadwick
Boseman dying in the plans that they had
for black panther 2 just being
completely just thrown off the table
obviously and having to come up with a
sequel for this and having to deal with
the loss of a character and the loss of
a friend to him it's hard especially
when they chose not to recast t'challa
and they do address that in this film
and I think they address it in a very
good way in a way that I think think
fans are actually going to be pretty
excited about for the most part for the
most part again I think this film's
going to be perfect for a lot of people
um
well I should say some people it's going
to be perfect for but I think the vast
majority of the people are going to kind
of put this film maybe like an 8 out of
10 which I think is kind of where I put
it because like I mentioned it does have
some flaws which we're going to talk
about in just a bit but I Want To Praise
Neymar no more he
he's a super cool villain to put to just
be so blunt about it he's just amazing I
enjoyed watching him just so much and I
know I look super white but my mom's
actually Mexican
um
so it's like seeing some of my Heritage
is really cool
um and I think a lot of the you know
Latina latinx people are going to really
like seeing that even texted some of my
friends I was like y'all are gonna love
Neymar like it's super it's super cool
to see on screen one thing I will say
about telecon
is they shot this differently than like
Aquaman they shout out to where it was
like
real
to where it's like you know if I jumped
underwater and you would just see you
know like my hair floating around stuff
like that's how they shot it like if
just any normal person jumped underwater
and you took a camera underwater that's
almost how it looks and it's not too big
of a distraction but I think I like how
they filmed
Aquaman a little bit better than that
just because it's a little bit more
clear just for like
Cinema you know what I mean just for
like the Cinematic purposes I think
shooting it the other way was better I
respect the creative decision to do this
for a more realistic approach
um but I think it would have worked
better better the other way now the
story overall
I think they did the absolute best they
could but the situation that they were
put in with the loss of Chadwick Bozeman
with the loss of t'challa obviously they
address his death and I know some people
were like don't use his death as a story
you know pushing a story inside of this
movie but
I think that all they could have
possibly done
without recasting now if they decided to
recast obviously that would be different
but they decided not to out of respect
for Chadwick and this is the best they
could have done I truly believe that I
really do this is uh again praise to
Ryan coogler because this
this will get you I cried I did multiple
times multiple times throughout this
movie uh it very much does take you
through the grieving process of all of
these characters who were so close with
him his mother his sister his friends
you know everyone akoi Nokia like it's
really cool and each character delivers
each character really delivers which
is great but at the same time this this
is one of the flaws of the movie so my
personal opinion
when I watch you know like a superhero
movie you have your villain which is
super strong in this movie
solid more than solid like really
incredible villain I I really like to
name more and then you have you know a
hero that's typically one hero that goes
up against him and this movie kind of
doesn't have that until like the the
very end right when you get the New
Black Panther so to me that's what it
lacked and I really felt that and
basically what I what I'm saying is is I
felt the the lack and the absence of of
Chadwick of t'challa you feel it in this
movie you you really do feel it in this
movie
um there's nothing you can do about that
and I and it's a good thing because
I want to miss him and I think a lot of
a lot of people want to miss him as well
but as far as like a story in the movie
purposes is concerned you feel the lack
of a really big main hero and that's
because we have so many other amazing
characters I'm not like trying to put
them down at all Queen raimonda and
Angela said I mean delivers an
incredible performance like incredible
she made me cry she made me cry [ __ ]
we're like really and the scene or the
scene the the movie takes some twists
that you don't necessarily expect it to
take
um
and
I'm not gonna say anything
um but no she delivers and all the the
actors deliver
but throughout the entire movie you are
focused on so many different characters
and for a good reason they're grieving
and you know you're seeing what they're
all going through individually but again
that focus is spread you know from Queen
raimonda to shuri akoy Nakia you know
Everett Ross is in this and Baku there's
a lot of
people in this that were following
around whereas for name War it's pretty
much Namor they give you the backstory
of it's not Atlantis I mean is but I
guess for legal purposes they couldn't
use it
um I I heard that but I always thought
it was just because they're really
trying to dive into you know kind of
like the ancient Mayan Aztec culture uh
which I prefer to believe over the legal
thing because it's just better but
Telecom
um is cool it's really really cool
um it's cool to see how they interact
with wakanda how you know Queen raimonda
and shuri interact with the more it's
really cool
um and there's a lot of cool things that
people are going to really like about
telecon and Neymar in general
um but it's all about him you know and
it's about him and his kingdom right
like they talk about the kingdom they
show you know his troops but it's really
still about him and one thing I will say
about the more is he's a pretty ruthless
villain
which is something I miss you know he's
just gonna do what he's got to do
um
and I like the fact that it's not just
to kind of rule the world just for the
sake of ruling it there's a good reason
of why him well telecon and wakanda go
to war with each other there's a good
reason
for other things that I won't mention
because it's spoiler free um but no he
was fantastic he really was fantastic
another flaws that the movie's long
for me a huge Marvel fan
um that's okay I'm all right with that
it didn't feel like it dragged really in
fact a lot of times I was really on kind
of the edge of my seat whether it was
watching a fight or not knowing what was
going to happen something like that you
know I I don't think it was too long I
think some people might though uh
especially if you're not like a die-hard
MCU fan if you're like a casual just
movie Watcher in general you might think
this movie's too long so that that might
affect some people but for me
it wasn't now on top of
the lack of like a main hero the
ending battle seemed kind of short to me
and that's because okay everybody knows
this isn't a spoiler they show it in the
trailer there's a new black panther
right I won't talk about who it is or
anything like that but pretty much the
fight between the New Black Panther and
Neymar could have been longer
um it really could because we have a big
final battle and a lot is happening
again we have so many characters and
they're all fighting Riri Williams is
iron heart
really cool I'm really excited for the
ironheart series after this it was
really cool to see her character but you
have her and then you have you know okui
and I think everybody knows about you
know the Midnight Angel and stuff like
that at this point in time
um that was really cool to see but it
was so much so much is happening at the
same time that the New Black Panther is
fighting the more and I'm like I could
have dealt with less of like the big
battle between everybody and more of
just like more versus Black Panther
that's what I wish I kind of got at the
end because it seemed kind of short so
if it was a little bit longer black
panther versus the more I would have
been a little bit more happy but overall
it's a really good movie it really is
it's not my favorite MCU movie and I
don't think it's right to compare this
movie to the first one they're very
different
um
and out of respect for Chadwick I think
a lot of people are going to say the
first one is better and I and I will say
that I I did miss
the Black Panther I missed t'challa and
you notice his absent you really you
really do you really do and it's sad but
again it's the best you can do with the
circumstances that they were put in now
to Amazon positives again I really did
love this movie there's so many great
things to love about it they do do a
tribute to Chadwick and it's really
emotional
even if you're not like an emotional
person you might cry in this movie
because I did and like
yeah
there's a lot there's a lot you know
like in the beginning and you feel him
throughout the entire thing the
beginning is so intense
um but the post-credits scene
they only showed one and it's not Doctor
Doom or anything like that
um there's rumors that they might add
that in don't rely on that but the
post-credits scene
that you see in this film
will tell your tear your heart out like
uh
it's it's really good for me personally
I I really I really enjoyed it there's a
lot of great things to this movie
there's a lot of great tributes to
Chadwick and again the acting is
phenomenal and overall the story is
really good I like I like what they
wrote as the story it makes sense right
it's not just some random thing and
we're watching some random Story play
out it makes sense the reason that the
memorial would want to fight wakanda the
reason that wakanda would want to fight
telecon like
it makes sense it really does and I
mentioned there's a lot of you know
characters and stuff and it's like but
all their stories are really good
it's just that lack of a hero a main
main main hero is uh what kind of just
doesn't make it live up to its full
potential to me but it's a super solid
movie it's a great movie it really is I
think everyone's going to love that I
don't think there are going to be people
that walk out of this movie and are like
it sucked
that wasn't a good movie I don't think
that's gonna happen I I don't I really
don't think it's gonna happen I think
people are going to walk out and say
like yeah it was good or they're gonna
be like yeah I love that movie and I'm
on the latter half I I really really
really liked it you could say I loved it
but I probably give it like an eight out
of ten some things could have been
different but overall great movie and
I'm really excited for everybody else to
see it let me know how excited you are
for it in the comments down below and if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos and as always I
will catch you all next time wolf
foreign